according to cyber security ventures the
global cyber crime cost is expected to
grow
and reach 10.5 trillion us dollars by
2025. that's the cost we have to pay for
cyber crimes
in this video we bring you the top 10
dangerous computer hackers of
all the time but before we begin if
you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
at number 10 we have johnson james
ancher in the year 2006 charleston james
angela of towney california
was charged for controlling huge number
of botnets
in other words hijacked computers
this was the first time that a hacker
was sent to prison
for the use of botnet technology and
should i use botnets
to compromise more than 400 000
computers
advertising companies paid him to
install adware or bots on specified
systems
it is also noted that ancieta advertised
the sale of his partners to those
interested in sending spam
or launching ddos attacks without being
identified
he was also pleaded guilty for infecting
machines at
two u.s military sites which earned him
more than
sixty one thousand dollars johnson james
angela was captured in a well-planned
and elaborate sting operation
when fbi agents coaxed him in their
office on the pretext of collecting
computer equipment
he was sentenced to nearly 60 months of
imprisonment
and was ordered to pay 15 000 us dollars
to the u.s federal government
for hacking their military computers at
number nine
we have andron lamo lamo began his
hacking journey by hacking
games he was more likely a gray hat
hacker
who wanted people to understand the
importance of internet security
however it went far ahead when he hacked
the new york times internet in 2002 he
was called
the homeless hacker for his transient
lifestyle and
he often had no fixed address he used to
hack
top-notch accounts by sitting in
cafeterias libraries
and so on he was convicted for
compromising security at the new york
times
microsoft and yahoo to name a few he
later gained the batch of an american
threat analyst
he also appeared on good morning america
fox news democracy now etc
as an expert on net centric crime and
incidents
lamo died in the year 2018 at the age of
37.
at number eight we have kevin paulsen a
former american black hat hacker
in the hacker community he is better
known as dark
dante at the age of 17 he hacked the us
department of defense
but he was left with a warning as he was
a miner
later in 1990 he propelled to stardom
for infiltrating a radio show calling
contest and
guaranteeing that he will be the 102nd
caller
to win the brand new porsche s2
the fbi stated perceiving paulson and
was soon arrested
and sentenced to a five years of
imprisonment
he was also barred from using a computer
or internet for three years
post his release later he took into
white hat hacking and journalism in the
year 2005
he became a senior editor of wired news
at number 7 we have the famous american
hacker
jonathan james better known as comrade
he was the first juvenile in the united
states to be sent to prison for hacking
this famous hack was his intrusion into
the defense threat reduction agency or
dtra computers a division of the united
states department of defense
he installed a backdoor on its servers
this enabled him to access over 3000
messages from government employees
various user names passwords and other
confidential data
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software
and this forced nasa to shut down
computers for three weeks
to fix the issue at an estimated cost of
41 000 american dollars
he was sentenced to six months arrest in
2000
he carried out his hacking using the
alias comrade
he specialized in hacking high-profile
garment systems however
he had a bitter ending in 2008 moving on
to a hacker at
number six at number six we have
anonymous
the anonymous group is an international
decentralized hacktivist movement that
is widely known for its cyber attacks
against
several governments its agencies and the
church of scientology
this group is focused on the concept of
social justice
the members of this group known as anons
are recognized in public by wearing
guy fox masks however some members cover
their face
without using the well-known masks as
well they are known as
being the digital robin hood amongst its
supporters
one of the noted incidents was in the
year 2008
when the group took up issue with the
church of scientology and began to
disable their websites
they are also known for hacking vatican
the fbi
paypal sony the cia mastercard
visa the israeli chinese tunisian
and ugandan governments while the law
enforcement agencies
and fbi have tracked down a few of the
group's members
the lack of any proper hierarchy makes
it almost impossible to distinguish or
eliminate
the anonymous groups as the whole at
number five we have the british du
mathew baven and richard price in 1994
the do hacked into multiple u.s military
systems including
the defense information system agency
griffis air force base
and the korean atomic research institute
they infiltrated into foreign systems by
transferring critical data of korean
atomic research institute
into the united states air force system
in 1996
babin was arrested for hacking incidents
related to u.s air force
defense manufacturer lockheed nasa and
nato
the pentagon described beaven as the
number one threat to u.s security and
possibly
the single biggest threat to world peace
since adolf hitler
however we even claims he was looking to
prove a ufo conspiracy theory
in 1997 price was fined 1200 pounds
after pleading guilty
to 12 offenses of gaining unauthorized
access to computer systems
in march and april 1994. having
malicious purposes or not
beaven and price displayed that even
military networks are vulnerable
now moving on to our hacker at number
four
at number four we have astra this hacker
is a tad bit different from the others
on this list as he has never been
publicly identified
the pen name of this hacker astra is a
sanskrit word
for a weapon in 2008 it was reported
that the authorities apprehended him
at that time he was known as a 58 year
old greek mathematician
he had into france's dissolve group
systems and got his hands on wonderful
weapons technology data
and then sold it to different countries
for a long period
astra was reported to have sold the data
to nearly 250 people from across the
world
this in turn cost the salt 360 million
us dollars of damage
while the astra's real identity was
never discovered
officials have said that he had been
wanted since the year 2002.
at number three we have the famous
american computer hacker
albert gonzalez he was responsible for
carrying
out multiple hacks he is accused of
masterminding the biggest fraud in
history
that is the combined credit card theft
and reselling of nearly
170 million card and atm numbers
from the year 2005 to 2007.
this shows how unsafe internet banking
can be at times
this was recorded to be one of the
biggest credit card thefts in history
he carried out this by installing a
sniffer albert gonzalez is
also said to have been the mastermind of
the tjx companies hack
wherein 45.6 million debit and
credit numbers were stolen later in 2010
he was sentenced to 20-year in
federal prison moving on to a hacker at
number two
at number two we have gary mckinson he
is a scottish
systems administrator and hacker accused
of carrying out the biggest
military computer hack of all time in
2002
he identified himself as solo through an
odd message on a u.s
army computer it was later found to be
gary mckinson
he was accused of infiltrating 97 united
states military and nasa computers by
installing virus
and deleting a few files over 13 months
between
february 2001 and march 2002 this was
the biggest
military computer attack of all time
this shutdown the u.s military's
washington network for 24 hours
what is fascinating is his reason that
much of his hacking was in search of
information on ufos
that he believed the u.s government was
hiding in its military computers
and finally let's see who we have at
number one
at number one we have kevin mitnick the
now affluent american entrepreneur was
one of the most wanted cyber criminal of
us once upon a time kevin who is
currently a security consultant was once
convicted of hacking motorola
nokia and pentagon kevin mastered
computer hacking and social engineering
early
and got his start as a team in 1982
he hacked north american defense command
this achievement inspired the 1983 film
war games in 1989 he hacked digital
equipment corporations network
and made copies of their software it's
largely believed that he once obtained
full control of
pacific pelz network to merely prove
that it could be done
he never exploited the data he obtained
according to reports
mitnick gained unauthorized access to a
dozens of computer networks
while he was a fugitive after five years
of imprisonment
mitnick started afresh and became a
security consultant
his knack with computers is still
remembered all of these hackers
were unbelievably skilled in cyber code
few of them faced jail in time a few of
others
ever since put their cyber skills to
better use by becoming
security advisors and helping humankind
hacking skills aren't a form of criminal
behavior
if it is put to good use so with that we
have come to an end of this video on
top 10 dangerous hackers of all time do
you agree with our list
if you are aware of any other great
computer hackers in history
let us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
you